I've had a lot of long plane flights in
my little pod by myself to just reflect
on my life and go like how did I get
here what is happening to me and it is
moments like that that I think about
talk about moments brie Larson just
experienced this one a wedding proposal
right in front of her and her facial
expressions say it all won't try to be
chill about the magical moment went down
at a spa makan in Chicago on Saturday
this guy John sham broen popped the
question to his boyfriend Richard Owen
during a meet-and-greet with brie and
now John is telling all 2et
Captain Marvel has always been my
favorite superhero since I was a kid and
our first real date was to see brie
Larson star as the mighty Captain Marvel
that was actually his first Marvel film
and he instantly fell in love with the
character and grade and if you think
that's cute wait till you hear this as
we walked up to brie I said Richard I
love you more than Captain Marvel will
you marry me I open the ring box and got
on one knee we were in tears and so was
brie he said yes and she actually helped
me put the ring on his finger and he
wasn't lying about Brie's reaction she
took to Twitter to reveal the moment
fully changed her quote y'all I was
present for a proposal and I am changed
much love to the happy couple
I would like to thank brie Larson and
East Comicon and a huge thank you to
Richard Owen for stealing my heart I
love you mm baby much love to you all